katia technique bonjour que doit-on
attendre de cette audience
aujourd'hui c'est une journée assez
exceptionnel puisque c'est le 11 c'est
le pardon le seul des onze prévenus à
être jugé pour complicité vous imaginez
donc qu'il aurait beaucoup à dire
d'ailleurs il le dit depuis ce matin
avec beaucoup de force beaucoup de
véhémence un il assez connue pour soleil
des cris qu'il est innocent qu'il n'a
rien à voir avec les faits reprochés
on lui reproche justement d'être le bras
droit dames et 10 coulibaly il nie il
dit qu' il a en effet bien vendu une
voiture pour lui c'est la seule chose
qu'ils reconnaissent mais que c'était
pour rembourser une dette
or on estime à la cour que il a vendu
avec une vente d'armes également liée à
cette mini cooper et donc lui ni en
disant qu' il ne s'agissait que de
rembourser cette dette et qui n'a rien à
voir avec des faits de terroristes alors
sinon qu'est ce qui se passe en fait au
fond de cette histoire c'est qu'il ya
quand même des choses qui sont à charge
pour ali riza paul est le principal
accusé sinon il ne serait pas accusé de
complicité et bien par exemple une liste
d'armes qu'on a retrouvé sur les lieux
sur les lieux de la vente de la mini
cooper et il dit que cette vente d'armes
étaient liés à un braquage qu'il
comptait faire et pas du tout un
attentat et puis secundo il ya bien une
les traces d'un désir de départ en syrie
après les attentats et lui dit qu'il se
rendait à damas n'est pas allée
finalement mais qui voulaient s'y rendre
mais certainement pas à l'état islamique
vous imaginez que cette version ne
convient pas du tout aux parties civiles
je vous propose d'écouter m corchia ce
sujet on appris des choses d'abord dans
la danse qu'il a dit est dans ce qu'il
n'a pas dit d'abord dans l'énervement
l'excitation
on avait un accusé aujourd'hui qui était
incontrôlable et incontrôlée qui perdait
ses moyens et qui perdait ses nerfs à de
très nombreuses reprises et à chaque
fois à des moments clés et par rapport à
des questions précises qui était posée
par le président de la cour d'assises
spécialement composée ça c'est la
première des choses puis deuxième chose
pour ne prendre qu'un exemple le
document écrit manuscrits dont ils
avaient contesté pendant cinq ans être
l'auteur où il demandait des armes et
des prix par rapport à des munitions et
par rapport à certaines
et bien ce document il a reconnu à
l'audience qu'il en était bien l'auteur
et effectivement c'est un c'est une
preuve importante qui l'a reconnu en
pleine audience
donc oui des éléments par rapport à ce
qu'il a pu dire et puis je dirais que le
principal c'est sans doute cette
sensation que nous avions tous de
l'entendre crier de l'entendre
manifester non pas des réponses mais les
cris en disant je ne voulais pas aller
en taule je ne voulais pas aller en
prison alors que le président
l'interrogé sur des faits extrêmement
précis et notamment la fuite
daly risa paul at juste après les
attentats lorsqu'il part au liban du 12
au 19 janvier et que du liban le 17
janvier
il essaie de prendre la fuite où il est
il décide de partir pour passer le poste
frontière de masnaa en syrie et ça c'est
effectivement aussi un élément charges
dont il est crucial de confronter à la
version d'alireza paulette avec celles
des autres accusés qui nie tout cela van
damme qui dit tous avoir été au courant
du projet terrorisé mehdi coulibaly et
pour le moment c'est la mère de l'accusé
qui est entendue ici au tribunal merci
beaucoup
quelle technique on le disait en direct
de la cour d'assises spéciale de paris
merci beaucoup